bien tout le monde sait squeeze
aujourd'hui on se trouve sur fortas mike
est un jeu d'horreur attention un peu
particulier parce qu'on a une arme
alarme dont on rêvait tant dans nos
classes ou danse länder où dans vanish
par bref dans tout le jeu d'horreur on a
toujours rêvé de tuer ces [ __ ] de
méchant qui font peur et aujourd'hui ça
va enfin pouvoir se réaliser start et la
lumière fut sebo qu'est ce qu'on a ici
un gun voilà le fameux à eux parfait
avoué le on a tous rêvé de trouver un
gun comme ça sur une table donc là c'est
clair malheureusement on n'avait que nos
jambes pour courir voilà en gros le mec
a entendu des bruits bizarres venant de
cette maison et personne ne le croyait
donc qui les a voulu venir voir lui-même
ce qui s'y passait rien apprendre la
voilà des balles c'est très bien ça ça
c'est quoi des flames et ben c'est parti
mon gars on se la joue rambo on se la
joue splinter cell moi je suis plutôt
rambo donc voilà je mets plutôt rambo
vrais moyens patron de mons donc ça me
fait plaisir je cherche la source
mes copains on ne me croyait pas je vais
leur prouver aux attentes mais j'ai
carrément la pression pourtant geingob
ça a pas du tout quoi je fais allumer sa
n'ont cessé ça vole elle fait peur ces
sales gosses et une lampe
elle est possédée cette [ __ ] de l'eau
alors là je suis rambo moi qu'est-ce qui
se passe
tiens balle dans le feu mon gars une
balle de gâcher d-kalck et c'est que ça
salut appuyé sur contrôle pour ta
croupir et tu pourra esquiver les
créatures joie de 6,5 et marqué à
l'écran donc ça me rassure pas trop ça
m'a téléporter déjà calé le bordel oh
oui c'est un truc là mais moi j'aimerais
moi dans cette histoire de complot
arrêté à y perdre est je tiens n'importe
où je suis décédé je suis probablement
déjà d'en faire à l'heure qu'il est bon
bah on recommence hu est un ballet quoi
le premier ennemi à qui on a un coup de
balai la dévastation de se terminer au
génie technique on va faire semblant
d'être innocent et noir mais avec un
balai on fera ça oh non je vais mourir
était qui s'approche suffisamment beach
avec le gun voilà c'est de ma stratégie
c'est tout sans commentaire une pièce je
pourrais la donner à un monde pour
qu'ils me laissent passer ça qui va se
passer
bon en gros on est obligé d'aller dans
cette [ __ ] de lumière qui nous
téléporte dans le trou du cul des
monstres alors attendez on va y aller
jouer discret un rôle à jouer mais
pourquoi il a une aura jaune au monde
est quelqu'un a appuyé sur mon écran
d'ordi ne savent pas du tout sans
déconner je vais allumer la lumière
non non moi je confonds de touche
regardez regardez cette silhouette c'est
un peu comme les filles qui veut faire
semblant d'avoir beaucoup de points td
beaucoup de face et ce con comme ça mais
en vrai c'est carrément l'extrême quoi
lasser la scoliose au stade maximale bon
on va se marrer je suis une lampe qui
bouge il nous personne avec moi au
mauvais chat un chat
arrête admea de vomir voilà
je sens pas voilà bientôt sonné aux deux
orages avaient pu parler à bercy
tonnerre on va l'esquivé comme ça la
contourne été bien compris tu as de
belfort oui tu peut séduire t'inquiète
pas atteint selon lui
mais dégage toi c'était très bien
lorsque je vais me le haut le pot ça
tombe c'est un canular ou une blague
pour une vidéo youtube je sais pas en
tout cas les caméras cachées s'est très
mal terminée quoi sexe waouh c'est quoi
ça je vis une hémorragie non mais c'est
pas moi ans tu te tais tu met un
pansement ou du dup sur tes cheveux j'en
sais rien au il ya des femmes là bas
qu'est ce qui se passe autre tout à
femme courbée
non non non j'ai justement une étagère
donc c'est pourquoi des boues des
modèles mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça
ta gueule scandaleux ça j'ai réussi deux
mois chercher les bougies le ski est pas
de courant je tombe sur une tête qui tu
vas aller vomir mais bougez moi je te le
dis au plateau renard the light
o o la venue du comme un ver on prie
pour que ça passe c'est papa sékouba les
coups bas les coups bas les coups bas
les coups bas les poubelles jetées toile
vont parler au moins 15 jours coumba les
têtes qui part est moi [ __ ] merde j'ai
tué alors bht mort totalement bien
nettoyer attendent justement de bien
nettoyer et ben non pas mon pote ballon
j'ai plus de balles
j'ai plus de balles me fais attaquer à
des bruits c'est de l'autre côté du mur
des débuts l'autre côté du mur [ __ ] de
nakivale dormir un non la vengeance sera
terrible
moi je nettoie le ventre des gens comme
ça sans permission sans mandat aux
immeubles il balaie tout en tentant mais
ça c'est scandaleux ça mais faut
prévenir que j'oublie des choses
pareilles image une étoile ventre ah non
à des balles ça dans les jeux d'horreur
y'en a pas un medic it
mais je peux pas j'ai toute ma vie très
bien on reviendra ici sur perdre la vie
2010 quitte mais c'est bien c'est parti
qui veut se rendre à coup de balai dans
le front direct via des moteurs genx à
charger comme ça pour un mec ça se
trouve je me dire bonjour et serrer la
main
merde et il me lâche rien et en plus si
cette femme courbée en fait feu et tué
des femmes sexy qu'on puisse aider grand
démon dégueulasse s'étaient pas
confirmées très fort pour ce genre de
chose la nuit je vais très souvent
toilettes dans le noir et du coup c'est
un peu au ttattola je peux pas tâtonner
ou tâter tout simplement dans trois
mètres cogner vous la tête contre
l'étagère nickel alors elle quitte mais
je m'en fous des medikits [ __ ] j'ai
toute ma vie et mec
regardez le regardez le
avec ses grands pieds là je suis pris un
bel effort de la poussière et aussi un
peu des mousses mais ça c'est pas ben en
l'air ou courbure en l'air c'est
pourquoi je suis sur un bon feeling le
jeu il fait ballon lucas tu te dois avec
nos jeux vidéo allez on quitte les mecs
j'ai fait un [ __ ] de l'attentât dans
cette maison c'est moi qui vous le dit
ou alors je vais manger des cigarettes
très bien et là mon gars là rambeau
octeau le bateau mais
bon allez vas-y on voit du faux je leur
dois être bombardés mon gars qu'est ce
tu crois combat dragon ball z
tu crois tu me fais peur tu crois tu me
fais peur je prépare une embuscade balle
est bonne et non pas des palettes on va
les bombes et les balles étaient pas les
têtes mali est balayé parce qu'il est
mort pour ça que ça a marché j'ai tu as
un mec avec mon balai but caché derrière
un poteau
lorsque tu as coups bas les balais bas
les ballets wittmann et bosses tu
m'avais sous-estimer les mecs
allez on dirait une sorte de chien on
dirait un chien l'ombre d'un chat
moyenne qu'un peu longue et pointue et
qovu du 8 au 12 août
tu as vraiment cher à la panne on bat
les étuves ababa balaye cet ado qui te
déplaît ça c'est le ballet plus agressif
du monde ça sera en vente que dans les
armureries bandar main pour pouvoir
m'acheter ce ballet vraiment ils tirent
même des balles par le manche
oh non mais c'est quoi ça toi toi tu
dégages déjà t'es pas une araignée le
videur de l'extrême a régné accepté au
nom a régné refusé dès maintenant voilà
ces nouvelles règles que jean store il
est peut-être pour dégager les araignées
balle et ça me semble plus convaincre
garde boom
voilà bien là hopla toujours douté pas
mais je fais un balai brosse attila pas
ce dernier elle me voit elle est le
centre non elle me ment ben voilà
monsieur fumée l'a appelée poulpe dans
le milieu de la mer en fait de partir du
moment où on va dans ce truc là haut up
ont été portés dans un monde générés
aléatoirement avec des monstres
aléatoire des fois là dedans au haut
c'est la salle qui permet de rêver ça je
revis que quand tu sors ya ce truc tenue
d'une tout fripé qui quittent dit
bonjour tout rêve s'écroule
instantanément tu brises des rêves et
des nettoyages nettoyage nettoyage des
tondeuses nettoyage de manière collector
voilà non non non non j'ai réveillé
l'autre si je vais dans cette salle il
peut pas venir
tiens-toi parfait on doit penser à nos
portes alors alors alors which is
alors monsieur poule pour s'ouvrir des
portes ok mais le mec tu passes à
travers les vitres comme ça mais c'est
lui qui cambriole des dizaines de
milliers de français chaque année [ __ ]
de l'agencé la fin de cette vidéo et de
cette mèche rebelle
j'espère si vous avez vu et si c'est le
cas comme d'habitude n'hésitez pas à
vous réincarner en coup de volant et a
braqué des camions glace à l'aide de vos
tentacules rebelles façon dont je
t'avais dans une nouvelle vidéo sur tout
le monde
[Musique]